[Musique]
Viola légère a eu droit une nouvelle
fois à des hommages chaleureux elle fut
pour beaucoup d'artistes une mentor une
collègue une grande sœur une petite sœur
aussi parfois et surtout une amie
honnête et sincère
[Musique]
de nombreux artistes ont tenu à être
présents à la cérémonie dont les
comédiens de la grande famille du pays
de la sagouinabouktouch ou elle a joué
d'innombrables fois son célèbres
personnages
elle nous a appris la magie qui existe
quand on plonge carré
âme dans le moment
quand on reste branché sur qui nous
sommes
et sur l'authenticité de ce que nous
avons à offrir
[Applaudissements]
Viola légère était une ancienne
religieuse enseignante devenue
comédienne et sénatrice il a joué la
Sagouine plus de 3000 fois son ami est
romancière anthonyme Mayet a enregistré
un message pour elle qui a été présenté
sous grand écran c'est un personnage
qui nous appartient à toutes les deux
parce que moi je l'ai écrit mais elle a
interprété la incarnée je lui ai donné
des mots elle lui a donné un coeur et
une âme je vous fais Chevalier de
l'Ordre des Arts et des Lettres madame
légère a reçu de nombreux prix pour sa
carrière et son talent et toujours et la
pensée à son équipe à raconter sa sœur
Viola disait
c'est moi qui reçoit les honneurs
mais tous ceux et toutes celles qui
m'ont entouré et qui m'entoure ont leur
part dans ce succès
autant aimé non seulement parce que tu
as touché tellement de gens par ton rôle
de la Sagouine mais aussi on t'a aimé à
cause des grandes qualités humaines
dans le gouverneur du Nouveau-Brunswick
a assisté aux funérailles tout comme de
nombreux politiciens et représentants
d'organismes Acadiens
[Musique]
c'est comme si que une maman est partie
c'est exactement ça
et c'est sur l'hymne national academia
que le cortège funèbre de viole la
légère a quitté la cathédrale ici une
chaise rideau Radio-Canada menthe